this is our last show that we're going
to be airing before valentine's day
and um so i needed to do this
valentine's day of course coming up
it's a very important time so we have a
new sponsor tonight
uh in honor of valentine's day uh
let me just say i'm gonna i don't know
what to say about this ad
that you're going to see right now i
don't know how to explain it i'm not
going to try
why don't we just show it and i'll
apologize afterwards
here we go love cream love
cream love cream this valentine's day
show the one you love how much you love
them with the one cream that says i love
you
love cream love cream is formulated to
provide the most love
possible use love cream full and
and also and this
or also love cream contains 50
more love than the leading brand of
cream based love
love cream here and love cream there
love cream for her and love cream for
him
love cream love cream love cream
love cream love cream
fallen cream all over again with love
cream
[Music]
okay and i'm sorry you know
there you have it i gotta get the love
cream
it was a journey it was a journey it was
a journey and
we've arrived